er wird der erde so nahe kommen dass man
die nicht nur wahrscheinlich mit bloßem
auge sehen kann er fliegt sogar näher an
der erde vorbei als die geostationären
satelliten über der erdoberfläche
positioniert sind und als er 2004
entdeckt wurde hat die chance für einen
einschlag auf der erde bei 2,7 prozent
also einer sehr hohen chance von eins zu
30 ob sie krieg substanzen wirklichen
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpassen wir nicht herzlich
willkommen der asteroid apophis ist groß
und gefährlich und er wird der erde sehr
nahe kommen 340 meter misst im
durchmesser und würde beim einschlag
eine katastrophe auslösen trotzdem sind
forscher und forscherinnen begeistert
wort ein objekt von dieser größe kommt
vielleicht alle tausend jahre der
maßnahme vorbei daher die aufregung wann
hat man schon einmal so eine chance das
sagt er mit forscher richard pinsel
jetzt wird also geplant welche missionen
man zu dem asteroiden unternehmen könnte
noch ist nämlich zeit denn erst am 13
april 2029 wird es soweit sein dann wird
man ihn von vielen orten aus
wahrscheinlich mit dem bloßen auge sehen
können wenn das wetter mitspielt er
fliegt unterhalb des orbits der
geostationären satelliten in einer
entfernung von rund 31.000 kilometern an
der erde vorbei deswegen sind die
forschungsteams auch vorsichtig ein
fehler bei einer mission könnte schon
die flugbahn verändern und ihn quasi auf
die erde schubsen
wir müssen
sehr vorsichtig sein denn bei diesen
bestimmten objekt wird es vielen
öffentlichen und politischen druck geben
nichts zu machen was seine flugbahn
beeinflussen könnte sagt james fayed ein
forscher der arizona state university
trotzdem wird zurzeit überlegt eine
mission zu den asteroiden zu schicken
die forscher im forscherin zeigen sich
begeistert über die möglichkeiten des
ereignisses ist eben eine riesige chance
für die astrophysik der vorbeiflug wird
übrigens ziemlich schnell vonstatten
gehen innerhalb von einer minute wird
apophis jeweils den durchmesser des
mondes am himmel zurücklegen
bei den vorbeiflug könnten zahlreiche
erkenntnisse über flugbahnen
beschaffenheit und mögliche aktionen
gegen hast du ihnen gewonnen werden
davide fahrer vom center for near earth
objects tradition ios wir wissen bereits
dass die enge begegnung mit der erde
april unfassbaren verändern wird aber
auch nächsten modelle zeigen auch dass
der enge vorbeiflug die art und weise
verändern könnte
wie sich diese hast du ihn dreht und es
ist möglich dass es einige oberflächen
veränderung geben wird wie kleine
lawinen und eins ist jetzt im vorfeld
klar
der hass sät wird nicht auf der erde
einschlagen inzwischen konnten deutlich
mehr erkenntnisse über seine flugbahn
gewonnen werden er wird eben sehr dicht
an der erde vorbeifliegen aber nicht
einschlagen apophis jahrtausendereignis
2029 chance für die wissenschaft
draufklicken gibt es noch mehr zum thema
profis anschauen und raumzeit block der
zukunft abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran